the Senate Intelligence Committee is
looking at social media for answers to
some of the questions about Russian
influence in the 2016 presidential
election this follows Facebook's
revelation that it found about 3,000 ads
containing messages about divisive
issues those ads were linked to about
470 inauthentic accounts and two Russian
trolls the New York Times magazine cover
story this weekend is RT Sputnik and
Russia's new theory of war how the
Kremlin built one of the most powerful
information weapons of the 21st century
and why it may be impossible to stop it
explores how Russia uses its
international cable network RT its
Kremlin run radio network Sputnik news
and social media platforms to spread
information to enhance political agendas
author in New York Times media columnist
Jim Ruttenberg is here Jim Wow
I mean this is an such an incredible
read first of all what did you find I
mean what I found was that there is a
powerful vast information network and by
the way I didn't find this further than
the United States intelligence community
or many agencies saw this and I was very
interested in the public face of this
campaign I mean half of the report that
they have several United States
intelligence agencies put out in January
was about RT a cable network that is
right in front of our face in fact
Michael Vickers who worked at the
Pentagon and intelligence analyst called
it the political equivalent of 9/11 how
did the Russians do it I mean whether
they swayed the ultimate result I think
will be debated for years to come but
what definitely what's going on what's
that the Russian Russian media plus
pro-russian internet activity
what's mixing it up in our political
debate in a major way that we know and
that's kind of unprecedented in my
lifetime covering policy and just for
reminding everybody that Russian media
is largely controlled by the government
yeah and we heard C ban until Charlie
Rose the other day that no there's
there's nothing to this Russian hacking
it's all a big forest it's all you know
people don't really understand do you
think we really the American people
really understand how serious and how
big this is I don't really don't think
we do I mean their investigations are
ongoing the
web we're only starting to understand
the way that all these pieces fit
together in the web in general I mean
beyond us this Russia story we're
talking about so I think that we need to
know a lot more before we say dismiss
this what sir in gold Jim what is it I
mean what what the intelligence
assessment said was its to kind of
pressure the the establishment
governments throughout the West piece
you say Russia's goal were to undermine
public faith in the US democratic
process denigrate Secretary Clinton and
harm her electability and this is going
on though in throughout Europe in
Germany so there is a campaign and it's
often about putting pressure on the
center of the establishment kind of
geopolitical foes of Russia from its own
flanks and reinforce and rebuild the
Russian Empire at least have some feel
the Emir Putin wants not free so what's
interesting here is that the Putin's
press secretary Dmitry Peskov told you
that this information war is actually a
counter campaign that they're responding
to something what is that me for years
we've heard out of Russia that you guys
in the West are causing trouble in our
backyard with your media with your NGOs
your nongovernmental organizations so
hey we have to come back we have to
fight back and get in this game and they
also I don't think they often
distinguish between CNN globally and
state media so we need something of our
own
so most Americans who are voting are not
watching Sputnik or RT which you can
find here in the United States but they
are on Facebook and there are on social
media we've heard Hillary Clinton an
interview just last night blaming
Facebook in many ways for being in some
ways my word is complicit I'm saying she
didn't use the word complicit but she's
suggesting that they are complicit what
role does facebook play in this I think
Facebook and we realizes this now
Facebook has got to tell us a lot more
about what it knows it has to keep
finding out and disclosing disclosing
disclosing if you were interacting with
content that we now have know is
identified as pro-russian or Russian
kind of information don't you deserve to
know that as a facebook user I mean
hopefully they'll get to a point where
they can tell their users hey that
person was a fraud or that account was a
fraud because they can be really
specific and who they target they can
target female voters between 25 and 34
in Ohio
you know who are singing I mean that's
the the Facebook targeting is can be
scary I mean let's face it
none of this works without a robust new
social media world like this is all new
and that enables this to happen RT on on
its own I don't think would get half of
the intelligent dossier
Geron Brooks thank you for a great
reading we should mention we did reach
out to RT & Sputnik we have not heard
back yet